[Music]
welcome to
wasn't that intro awesome it was made by
whatever name I put down there
hey forgot it was really cool he spent a
lot of time on it I got a lot of great
intro this week so if you made a really
special one don't worry I'll still put
it up for you having a really awesome
week
you have to stop snoring I'm trying to
record here we might have a lot of new
Bros and they brought me today since I
had a really crazy week last week for
those of you don't know what this is
basically my weekly check-in with you
brownish to make sure everything's all
right
everything's cool so person you wanna
kick on the web yeah buddy I feel like
we we got what was rightfully ours all
along I'm really happy that you know
together we can donate in total I guess
nine thousand plus the thing from king
of the web so oh god Matt ten thousand
five hundred use American dollars
towards WWF or charity basically it's
really cool that's you know together as
a fan group we can do something towards
someone else basically I'm I'm really
happy a lot of you bros having saying
like yeah buddy you should may perhaps
consider keeping some of the money for
yourself if you know what I mean
for the project I don't know like I
think anyone who's not rich as hell
could use that type of money I'm no
exception I'm trying to save for a car
I'm moving the ethylene since I'm gonna
need money for that and stuff like that
so basically everyone can use that money
but it's easy to just keep thinking
about yourself all the time
so I wanted to break away from that and
think of someone else and something else
so I wanted to donate it to WWE I will
make a video as soon as I receive the
winnings showing that that I actually
donate it so yeah I really want to thank
you both for being so supportive I will
thank you bros a million times more I
already have thank you million I'm like
I feel so undeserving of having such an
awesome fan base really either I don't
know what I do it's like all I do is
make videos and you bros just keep
staying so awesome and then I couldn't
be more happy about it so and I think
this king of the web competition really
show like how awesome in a new bros are
the strength of the bro army pretty much
all right so I don't think I have much
playing some video games all right so as
always I'm just warming up here this is
Mike how you doing it's like you started
doing this and I was like what are you
doing I'm charging my broke head
oh all right here we go are you ready
bro there we go all right
[Music]
you